مساء الخير هناك ساعات موجوده في جميع
ارجاء المعموره كل الصراع منهم بيمثل مربع
صغير على رقعه شطرنج كبيره جدا وبدات
اطرافها الاساسيه او اللي ب يجلس على رقعه
الشطرنج الكبيره دي بحركه القطع المختلفه
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها من جانب تقدر
تعتبرهم الاتحاد الاوروبي والى حد ما الهن
وعلى الجانب الاخر هناك الصين وروسيا
وايران اللعب الكبرى بين هذه الدول اللي
هي محاوله من الولايات المتحده وخلافات
الجهات صعود الصين ومعها حلفائها شرفهم
اللعبه الكبرى دي ممكن يكون اسهل مدخل ان
احنا نعرفه قسم من البدايه اللي احنا
حكينا اكثر من مره كان الوضع العالمي كله
مستقر بوجود الولايات المتحده فوق الحرم
العالمي السيد العالم كله ثم كانت الصين
اول بلد يلقي خطر على هذا النظام العالمي
ل ما ادري تنجح بان تحقق
معدلات نمو مذهله جدا لسنوات طويله واصبحت
الان الاقتصاد رقم اثنين في العالم هو
بمعايير يعني هي من حيث الناتج المحلي
العالم الناتج المحلي الاجمالي هي رقم
اثنين او بمعايير اخرى تكلمنا عنها قبل
كده معايير المعادله القوى الشرعيه هي
القوه الاقتصاديه رقم واحد الولايات
المتحده مدركه ان تصدر القوى الاساسي
للصين هي قدرتها الكبيره جدا على الانتاج
قدرتها على الانتاج بشكل يمكنها من اغلاق
اسواق العالم كلها في بضائعها وتدرك ايضا
ان القوه الصينيه مكان ضعف وتحاول ضرب
بالصين في مكامن الضعف او في نقاط الضعف
ال بشكل مبكر يمكنها من الصين ايضا من
الضعف متعدده منها مثلا محاوله الامريكان
الحلفاء الغربيين قطع الطريق
على الوصول الى التكنولوجيا الغربيه
محاوله قطع الصين على الدخول الى بعض
الاسواق وتحديدا السوق الامريكي انما نقطه
الضعف الاساسيه اللي تدركها الولايات
المتحده وهي احتيال الصين المستمره الى
البطوله والغاز خصوصا من منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والخليج
هذا البترول والغاز في
شان وشعبه كل البضائع والتجار ثانيه تسعين
في المائه منه بينتقل عبر البحر
وعشان ينتقل عبر البحر يعني لازم هايبر من
الممرات الملاحيه المعروفه اللي بتتعدى
فيها صالحه للملاحه لكل ناقلات النفط وكل
ناقلات الغاز ولابد ان تمر عبر الممرات
البحريه او المضيق البحريه زي اخر مو زي م
لقي الى اخره والولايات المتحده تسيطر على
كل المعابر البحريه المهمه وكل ال مضايق
في كل مكان في العالم وبالتالي الولايات
المتحده والصين يدركون ان الاقتصاد الصيني
تحت رحمه السلاح الامريكي وان الامريكان
في حال وجود اي نزاع يستطيعون شل الاقتصاد
الصيني بحرمانه من شريان الحياه اليه وهو
البطوله والغاز
الفلسطينيين بيحاولوا يعملوا اه اه
استراتيجيه مطاطه الاستراتجيه تقوم على
فكره تطوير القدرات العسكريه الصينيه
وخصوصا الاسطول الامر الثاني هو ايجاد
بدائل
للحصول على البترول والغاز عن طرق او من
اماكن لا تخضع للسيطره الامريكيه ممكن
يعملوا هو الهدف الاساسي من مشروع او
مبادره الحزام والطريق الحقيقه هو احد
الاهداف الرئيسه هو ايجاد بدائل طرق بريه
تنقل
البترول والغاز من دول المنطقه الى الصين
بعيدا عن السيطره الامريكيه
وهو داء الامريكان بلحظه من المشاريع
المختلفه اللي بتحول تعقدها الصيني انشاء
ممرات اه بريه يعني ت نقل الغاز تنقل
البطوله والغاز عن طريق طرق بريه او م او
طيب وينزل الغاز والبترول تقرير البنتاغون
للكونغرس اه 2016 بيقول ان الصينيين
بيحاولوا لكن على الارجح محاوله
بالاستغناء او تقليل الاعتماد
على الممرات البحريه التي تخضع لسيطره
الولايات المتحده سوف تكون محدوده ما
بيتكلم على الحاضر لكن المستقبل قد يكون
مختلف
الصينيين اذا ادراكهم للحقيقه دي ويدرك هم
الى السيطره والتفوق البحري الامريكي
تخوفهم من ان يظلوا طوال الوقت تحت رحمه
الامريكان بداوا يفكروا بشكل مختلف
انه فيه دولتين
بيختلف فيهم ميزات ان تختلف معه متميزه مع
كل دول العالم
دولتين دول هما روسيا وايران اللي موجودين
عند روسيا وايران الميزه الاولنيه ان
كلاهما كل واحده فيهم تمتلك من احتياطات
الغاز والبترول اللي ممكن يؤمن احتياجات
الصين لسنوات طويله قادمه
الميزه الثانيه ان البلدين الحرج المعسكر
الامريكي يعني مش تحت سيطره النفوذ
الامريكي من حيث القدره مثلا
الروس عندهم كميات كبيره من البترول
الاحتياطات المؤكده وفقا لتقديرات وكاله
معلومات الطاقه الامريكيه للصراع
الاحصائيه لوزاره
الطاقه الامريكيه بتقول انه وافق 2015
الاحتياطات المبكره عند الروس اللي بينطلق
15 11 مليون مربيه يومين احتضن المبكره 8
برميل نفط ومن حيث الغاز هم اكبر بلد من
حيث كميات الغاز عندهم اكثر من 1600
ترليون قدم مكعب تحت الارض
بالنسبه لي
لايران
مائه ثمانيه وخمسين مليار برميل يعني هي
رابع اكبر احتياطي في العالم بعد فنزويلا
والسعوديه وكانت
والامن حيث الغاز عندها اكثر من الف
ومائتين مليون قدم مكعب يعني هي رقم اثنين
بعض روسيا فكلاهما عنده قدره ان يوفر
احتياجات الصين هي احتياجات الصين نفس
الوكاله الضرب حسبت امكانيات الصين
المحليه يعني قدراتها اللي موجوده عندهم
هي عندها طاقه بردو وحسبت معدلات نمو
والانسان 35
الصينيين يحتاجوا الواردات يوميه قدرها
تسعه وسبعه من عشره مليون برميل
وتحتاج في السنه 6 تريليون قدم مكعب من
الغاز
لما تشوف الكميات دي قدره الروس قادرين
انه هما يوفروا هذه الكميات تقريبا كامل
تهم او على الاقل يوفر من الخمسه وسبعين
في المائه وفقا لتقديرات الوكاله في اضعف
الايمان
الايرانيون اذا رفعت عنهم الحصار والضغوط
الامريكيه وبدؤوا في تطوير قدراتهم
المختلفه على انتاج الغاز والبترول
الضروره كل احتياجات الصين لسنوات طويله
علشان كده الصين ادركتها بيه البلدين
دوليه
وتاكد اتفاقات من وقت مبكر وشراكه بين
البلدين ايم على مقايضه بسيطه جدا امني
الامن الطاقه في في المقابل امنكم
الاقتصادي يعني الصوره عندها امكانيات
ماليه ضخمه لكن ما عندهاش هو رمز
والبترول والغاز بيمثل مصدر الدخل الرئيسي
ل ل روسيا وايران فهي الى اتفاق قائم على
هذا الاساس وفر والاحتياجات الاساسيه من
البترول والغاز
وانا بشراء لهذا البترول والغاز اوفر لكم
احتياجاتكم الاساسيه او مصدر الدخل
الاساسي لكم من العمله الصعبه هذه الفكره
قائمه بين البلدين او بين الصين من ناحيه
وايران وروسيا من ناحيه اخرى تبدا يترجم
في شكل مشروعات
وطبعا البلاد وخارج المعسكر خارج بيت
الطاعه الامريكي
فبدا مثلا اه من وقت مبكر من عده ساعات
البلدين بيحاولوا اللي هما الصين وروسيا
اللي بينهم حدود اكثر من اربعه الاف
كيلومتر حدود مشتركه انه يتفقوا على خطوط
انابيب نقل الغاز والبترول الروسي الى
الصين المساله محتاجه له محتاجه فلوس
الفلوس موجوده والوقت اخرون المشروع الذي
اخذ التطور تاخذ عشره عشرين سنه لكنهم
شغالين في الاطار
بالنسبه لايران بردو في شركات قائمه
والصين بتشتري معظم الانتاج البطوله اللي
بتدوب وايران وعاوزه تحصل ايضا على ايران
بشكل اكبر ما فيش حدود مشتركه ما بين
روسيا وايران لكن في بلد مهمه مشتركه جدا
وقع فيه يعني هذا الصراع الكبير هي
باكستاني باكستان حليف
من اكثر من خمسين سنه في معركتها مع الهند
يعني
يعني الصين عدو كانت عدو الهند وباكستان
ما زالت عدول الهند والصين وباكستان
حليفين منذ اكثر من خمسين سنه مؤخرا السن
قرارات انها تستثمر اكثر من سته واربعين
مليون مليار دولار في مشروع اللي هو الممر
الاقتصادي اللي قوامه او اهم مشروع في
اللي سمعناه في الدول العربيه هنا اللي هو
بوادر اللي موجود على بحر العرب بالقرب من
الخليج الخليج العربي
الفكره بايجاز انها توصل الى الخليج
العربي مباشره عن طريق الصين وبالتالي
الخليج العربي وبحر العرب عن الصيغ عن
طريق ال ال ال ال المجره عن طريق ال ال
بورت او الماليه الباكستاني مما يحمل
الكثير جدا او بنفس مهم جدا
غرب الصين وبحر العرب وبالتالي اه اه
كل بقي المحيط الهندي كل الكلام ده جيد
جدا لكن كما لي هدف ثاني ان تكون باكستان
معبر الى انابيب النفط والغاز الايرانيه
الى الصين
الاقتصاديه تجري
العوائق على الحدود ما بين باكستان وايران
هناك اقليه البلوش او قبائل البلوش ودي
قبائل جزء منها عنده ميول انفصاليه عن
باكستان بل ان جزء منهم بيقع على الحدود
ما بين ايران وباكستان بمثل المشكله لا
باكستان ومشكله ايضا لايران بسبب رغبتهم
الانفصاليه في نفس المنطقه هناك مجموعات
متطرفه سنيه بتحاول استهداف ايران على
اساس طائفي والولايات المتحده تستثمر في
الطموحات
القوميه البلوش وتستثمر ايضا في الافكار
المتطرفه لهذه جماعات بهدف زعزعه
الاستقرار
على الحدود الايرانيه مش برضاهم
مخاوف حلفائها العرب في غرب الخليج العربي
ولكن رغبه منها ضمن اسباب اخرى في الضرب
التحالف اللي ممكن يقوم بشكل قوي ما بين
ايران وبين الصين اللعبه الاساسيه هو ضرب
هذا التحالف هي مش هتقدر تعمل كثير عشان
تضرب العلاقه ما تقدرش تسيطر على العلاقه
كثير ما بين الصين والروسي لكن هي تدرك
ايضا انه رغم انه فيه مصالح ما بين الروس
والصين لكن لهم خلافات تاريخيه كثيره
يعني مواجهات وبالتالي اقليم لم تطمئن
تماما ان هي اضطرهم كل مقدرتها على اساس
استيراد النفط من الروس والسله تستطيع ان
تامن تماما ان امنها كله بان هي تلقى بكل
ثقلها وكل صدارتها تبقى تحت رحمه الصينيين
في النهايه هما تجمعهم مصلحه الان قد
تتغير كما تغيرت الظروف في اوقات كثيره من
التاريخ بين العملاقين الروس
والصينيين وبالتالي الصين بدور على بديل
ووجه في البديل في ايران وامريكا مدركه
لهذا الخطر علشان كده احد استهداف ايران
مش اللي هي بتهدد دول الخليج بسبب طبعا
موجود وقائم ولكن لانها جزء من مخطط كبير
تحالف قائم الان ابيض من ثلاث دول هي
مناوئه للولايات المتحده
وهذا هي اللعبه الكبرى اللي كمان بتطور
رحاها خارج المنطقه لان تكلمت عليها عشان
طب وفي كامل منطقه المحيط الهندي ال ان
شاء الله في حلقه اخرى باذن الله اشكركم
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]